old man sauna took it and lied about it
[Music]
so I'm Jeremy number way and we are gym
employees playing never I dieted I work
at CrossFit a CrossFit gym in Studio
City
I've been working there about four years
now altogether I will get 24-hour
Fitness two years and I'm a survivor I
worked at mountainside fitness for ten
years starting at the front desk I work
at one of those maintained type of gyms
where you gonna get your standard
membership I've been there for almost a
year now I work around it for now I also
work the front desk
I love the fitness industry everybody
that comes into the gym is there for a
reason to better themselves and so it's
really cool to be around people like
that that's why I like it I always say
the same thing like I've been a fan of
fitness for a long time all right so
let's play something never ever let's do
it never have ever roasted someone's
account photo after they signed in I
have but there are done ones where
people are making like silly faces and I
laugh but like I think that was Ben 10
and I had a guy that wanted to show off
his lip tattoo and he's pulled his lips
down but you couldn't you didn't see his
face so the first thing you see when you
like scanned a man is just this lip
tattoo and it caught me off guard I had
to make him show me his lip tattoo in
order to get into the gym and my job we
don't had our photo a lot of times the
members don't want to take the photo so
a lot of times they'll just sit there
like this
never have I ever had to call the cops
on someone at the gym definitely hair I
have never had to call the cops on
anybody but I've heard stories and I
haven't personally called the police on
anyone either
but we're next door to a cafe with a bar
and some guy came out super drunk and
one of the
just went out there they got into an
altercation so that the police were
called that day one of the guests come
give me like it is doing the locker room
here I can all crazy whatever so I go in
there dude butt-naked like walking
around the gym looking like Macho Man
Randy Savage at that point I was like
man can you put your clothes on he like
no I was like well I'm calling the
police they looking for a minute in the
locker room they can't find them I see
you in the shower beating up where the
police ended up getting them dressed but
they got him out the gym everybody knows
when you playing basketball in gym
there's a guy in there that still thinks
that he can play thinks that he can
still go to the NBA playing against
young kids and he got into an
altercation with one of the kids the sad
thing is is I had to get the younger kid
who was like 13 or 14 years old off of
him and then eventually had to call the
police
because he wanted to fight the
thirteen-year-old and get a Redemption
shot in never ever ever took a photo or
video of someone and sent it to a friend
I have not videos that's like a gym know
like you can't mess with people in if
again it's like a sanctuary and it's
crossing boundaries
I have not although there was one moment
I was tempted to this guy was sitting
cross-legged crowd like doing one of the
ab rollers and he's just like this like
is that a thing never have I ever been
approached for conversation I make in
person in a locker room yes I had and I
don't engage I ain't talking to no [ __ ]
do I have and I don't understand why
some people do it was always that one
guy in the lab who just wants to have a
full-fledged conversation with you while
he's back I have it was in a very
uncomfortable place I was cleaning the
locker rooms and that was my back was
against the lockers and he comes up and
he's talking to me so there's no way for
me to really get around the conversation
no one's ever talked to me while naked
but they do some weird things I was in
the sauna and this lady's just like
rubbing herself never have I ever worked
out in the middle of a ship without
permission
absolutely I did it last week as a
matter of fact I overslept so
well supposed to work at night there was
a class at 7:45 so he's gonna in the
middle of it I'm gonna take this class I
never said anything so I still clocked
in sorry Chuck definitely have I gotta
get your Phillips in and you can't I've
never done that
so working a shift
closing shifts with one my friends we're
having a good time at the front desk and
we have a basketball court and he
started talking so we instead of just
sitting there and there was nobody in
the gym we were just like well let's go
ahead and handle this and for the last
20 minutes of our ship we played
one-on-one never have I ever wanted to
quit midships I'd say yeah definitely
yeah
old man sauna took it and lied about it
just again I really liked working there
and I loved being there so there was a
guy that came out and he was like it
smells really bad ass on it so I was
like okay I'll go in there and it
smelled rancid in the sauna and as I'm
coming out I noticed that this guy is
bending over at the toilet stalls and
the stall is not closed and his pants
are down and he's grabbing toilet papers
I had to walk over to him like excuse me
sir like do you know what happened
inside the sauna and he's like I don't
[Music]
deal with this retun anyway yeah that
was yeah they got used to me and they
started to treat me like family is that
one time I had to go and I went to this
went to executive locker room in the
toilets is crazy
I definitely want to quit never have I
ever caught or known of people getting
freaky at the gym I never caught on
buddy but I for sure have heard of some
stories
a heaven sauna steam room
showers massage room wha not in the gym
but other stuff that I know I think it's
this at the gym or at the gym theater
room basketball court then there you get
it in however you can get it in every
time somebody gets caught I'm nicely
shot good I have this never have I ever
saw Miss and left it because it was too
disgusting I have there's been times
where I'm like I'm not cleaning I'm not
cleaning up no Dookie it's been times
where I'm like I got text the owner and
be like listen this happened I'm not
doing it never have i everybody hit on
someone at the gym while I was working I
have not be a little flirty at times you
know a single guy there's some
attractive women there when people talk
to me they like her interesting hate on
people I just it was never something
else for me you never like you know fish
in the same pond with me I definitely
thought about it but I always like man
can't make no move like this never ever
ever looked at someone lifting it
imagined that's what they looked like
taking them to I think that'd be weird
it'd be really concerning if somebody
was doing this those were some very
interesting questions definitely someone
caught me off guard I definitely know
now that my gym is not as bad as I think
it is now we know what people want to
know about the gym I guess you guys now
see what gym employees experience yeah
and if you have any more questions you
want us to answer or any more never have
I ever leave them in the comments below
[Music]